la inmigración irregular es nuevamente
campo de batalla en temporada electoral
tras haber sido enviado sin previo aviso
al balneario turístico de marta's en el
estado de Massachusetts estos
indocumentados en su mayoría venezolanos
Fueron trasladados por orden del
gobernador a la base militar ded
preparada para situaciones de emergencia
Defensores de los derechos de los
migrantes se les ofrecieron ayuda y
criticaron este proceder de las
autoridades republicanas del Sur del
país puede ser irónico que esté mejor
aquí en Massachusetts que en Texas pero
la realidad es que nunca deberían
haberlos puesto en esta posición porque
no se sabe que les pudo haber pasado el
traslado diopía al gobernador de la
Florida rondesantis para defender su
decisión de enviarlos al norte y para
arremeter contra la supuesta doble moral
de los estados tradicionalmente Azules
con políticas más tolerantes con los
inmigrantes
Esta es una política masiva intencionada
que está causando un enorme daño en todo
el país y todo tiene su origen en la
capacidad de bailen de ocuparse de que
las leyes se ejecuten fielmente y de
cumplir su juramento Así que en lugar de
preocuparse por un puñado de gente rica
y porque tengan 50 inmigrantes a Por
cierto ya los han echado ya se han ido
dicen que quieren a todos que nadie es
ilegal y lo sacaron en 48 horas
para la casa blanca el accionar de los
republicanos es claro usan a los
indocumentados como peones políticos de
Cara a las elecciones de medio término
eran niños eran madres que huían del
comunismo y que les hicieron el
gobernador de santis y el gobernador
nosotros tratan como bienes materiales
en un truco político cruel y premeditado
ya son al menos 10.000 inmigrantes los
que han sido enviados desde Texas y
Arizona trasladados a territorios
controlados por demócratas como Nueva
York y Washington